foreign thank you
the golden state has a snitch line for
hate California promotes squealing if
someone hurts your feelings it's true
greasy-haired goon Gavin Newsom recently
announced his state will be launching a
hotline for reporting acts of hate
according to the website examples of
hate incidents include name-calling
bullying or refusing service or as I
call them the three pillars of good
management
[Laughter]
ask my staff if you can still find them
the project known as California versus
hate will allow victims and witnesses to
report a hate incident against any group
in a safe Anonymous manner because
California won't tolerate hate unless
you hate Street crime or drug abuse and
public pooping in that case you're out
of luck
and who gets to Define what a hate crime
is right for some it's suffering through
a new song by the Red Hot Chili Peppers
for others it's suffering through an old
song by the Red Hot Chili Peppers
because they suck
according to new some a hate Act is
vaguely defined as any hostile
expression or action against someone's
actual or perceived identity perfect
example telling Leah Thomas the pool's
so cold it'll give her shrinkage
telling Rachel dolezal that she owes
reparations
foreign
or telling Brian kill me he's got to go
home
snitch line but the best part law
enforcement won't be involved so I guess
it's like how California handles murder
rape and theft that again maybe having a
place to report hostility isn't all bad
we've actually obtained tape of a few of
the calls
hello California hate hotline how can I
help you yeah uh my boss keeps telling
people that I'm a drug addicted
alcoholic how many people is he telling
uh like a couple million every night wow
that's messed up anything else yeah he
also won't stop talking about his abs
quads and biceps has he threatened you
oh no no no no no he's super tiny like
crazy small
pick him up and hold him like a baby
yeah he won't stop talking about his
ass sounds like he's obsessed
I'll
a link
thank you sir
Iris this is do you think this is like
the most necessary thing yes yes
ah give the police a break let Karen
call somebody else this is great
it's a good idea
are the police involved no shut up Karen
like what I mean literally it's a
tattletail hotline yes but we talked
about this before this is how they don't
have to deal with it anymore right we
did this you know like now they can call
a line and they'll be save it and
they'll go in a little box it's like
Dwight shoot in the office his complaint
box and he'll keep it in Sacramento and
the good news is they'll have fresh
toilet paper for everybody crapping
outside so it'll work out just fine yeah
I did
and Molly I I I felt like oh like
they're allowing all the other crimes to
occur and this is the one they're gonna
they're gonna care about that the
feelings that are hurt but tyrus's point
is that like they're just trying to
shunt it off like the reparations
discussion like like let's have it and
not do anything yeah but I worry if you
don't have the place involved who is
involved and you know there's like no
due process here so you make a complaint
about someone and then some other state
agency gets involved to punish you
and it's all based on Anonymous
complaints so like you lose out housing
or you lose out benefits or something
like that like what's the whole point of
this because it's not just going into an
empty box
where could it be going if it's not yeah
a social worker is going to come sit me
down and talk about my feelings so no
this is the problem is feelings aren't
facts so someone says he looked at me
the wrong way or they gave me bad
service I want something done the 10-day
the hundreds of phone calls that tie up
police officers and correctional
facilities and all this stuff now
they've got their own hotline they
promise no police are involved so if I'm
not breaking a law in law enforcement I
don't care okay but think about where
these normally are they're on college
campuses where the police are not
involved and they'll you know people
will make an anonymous complaint it will
destroy someone's life they get kicked
off campus and it's like that ideology
is now transported to the entire State
of California well Kat could this be
therapeutic for someone who just needs
to vent their problems like perhaps me
yes
no and I I have a lot of problems
but I've never had a problem where I'm
going to feel better by calling a
hotline like this because it's a
government hotline so what's going to
happen when you call you're gonna be put
on hold
you're gonna be put on hold for a very
long time and nothing pisses you off
even more when you're upset than being
put on holds and then the little music
while you're on hold and you're already
upset and then you finally get through
and what are they gonna say they're
gonna hit you with I'm so sorry to hear
that Ma'am why don't I just call the DMV
like that already exists I would so
volunteer for this program just to take
these calls and just screw with them
it's just
this already exists it's every
government office ever you call you tell
them things you wait and you tell them
things they can't do anything they say
ma'am you're so sorry to hear that and
you're like I'm not that old don't call
me ma'am
by the way the whole music will be the
Red Hot Chili Pepper yes
Californication so okay
technically the Red Hot Chili Peppers
could call a complaint about me because
of the things I say I slandered them guy
so two points number one they say the
police won't get involved I don't
believe them really I think that this
goes into some database somewhere and
will be weaponized by someone at some
point whether it's the police or not
second thought this is about people who
feel like there's an affront to
someone's perceived identity
there are a lot of Californians in the
last few years who have a brand new
identity Floridians right uh Texans and
so my thought process is can they maybe
dial up the hotline the old hate line
and explain how much they hate their
former State and why that would be
worthwhile that's an excellent idea that
would be worth this Blood the lines they
should have a maybe this this is kind of
a hotline for people to nark on people
who narc right they're just collecting
really yeah and it goes in a circle
because if you call on me then I will
call on you we'll just keep calling on
each other exactly they reported me well
he reported me he made me feel bad when
he reported me well he made me feel
worse when he reported me
this is going to destroy relationships
too because imagine if you are venting
to a friend and your friend says to you
why don't you call the government
hotline
phone book the giant thing and he wore a
suit with little question marks on it I
don't remember who it is that's going
nowhere obviously in this segment
remember Riddler no yo he looks like the
Riddler he's like you can get all this
free stuff from a government program ask
lesko
right the little kid got it do I win
something
you get a prize but you don't do you guy
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else